hi there steve goffin here again talking
about languages and today i'm going to
talk about getting started in a language
and you'll have to bear with me because
i'm kind of going to sort my thoughts
out as i as i speak
um
getting
started um
there are starter books
there are in fact if you google getting
started in a language you'll find lots
of advice
uh different
you know blogs language blobs blogs have
posted
you know advice you know put
find 50 words and
and put stickies all over the house with
those 50 words and think of those 50
words or
you know start speaking from day one
with phrases that you have
uh i asked my wife what she would do and
she said boy you know i might go
look at a movie or
and which is not a bad idea because it
kind of gets you stimulated
um
when i studied the chinese we started
into these uh
dialogues
uh which were written in pinyin in other
words in a romanized alphabet not in
characters and we listened to them for
two months and then we launched right
into uh reading newspapers and stuff
like that
uh of course learning characters
and uh and there's an expression in
russian uh nacho
palavina
in other words if i remember correctly
uh
the beginning is half the
deal or half the the job
and of course it is important to get
started
however
more and more i think it almost doesn't
matter what you do at the beginning
because
you know in every language that i've
learned
the beginning part
is such a small part of the total
process
because to me if i learn a language i
want to learn it to a
decent level of fluency i want to get to
a level where i understand so that i can
have meaningful conversations with
people on a range of subjects
possibly get into reading possibly
understanding movies
kind of feel comfortable in the language
not perfect but comfortable and to get
to that level actually takes a long long
time i get back to my old
inverted hockey stick where you have
that initial the the beginner period
where you're you feel like you're making
quite a lot of progress and you're
struggling but you're seeing the results
of your effort and then there's that
long long period where you are gradually
increasing your familiarity
words that you you know learn and forget
and learn and forget that eventually
start to stick and so that that sort of
comfortable competence competence in the
language takes a long time
so i guess the gist of it is
what you do at the beginning whether you
speak don't speak
whether you i mean certainly watch
movies to stimulate you but you won't be
learning the language from it
uh
you know but and do have a look at the
sort of advice that people have put in
different blogs but but all of this what
it does
it gets you to commit to the language
and depending on your personality you
may be
you know better you know able to commit
to the language if you can start
speaking early
or if you are into music
or anything like that that gets you
motivated to get out the language but
you will find that it it almost doesn't
matter what you do at the beginning in
my view and i don't believe that you can
ingrain mistakes or any of this stuff
i genuinely believe because i've started
languages in different ways
and it is such a long haul
that when i think back you know the
amount of time spent in that initial
beginner stage is relatively small now i
recognize that a majority of people
never ever leave the beginner stage they
never get beyond that level where they
can say a few things and don't really
understand too well what people say back
at them never achieve that level of
comfort
so i would say to people recognize that
the important thing
is not what you do at the beginning the
important thing is that you stay with it
and you stay with it for the long haul
because it does take a lot of time to
achieve that level of of proficiency and
comprehension that i think is is the
mark of fluency so again it depends on
what your goals are but they're just the
thought on
sort of getting started in a language do
whatever motivates you to get started
with the language and if you don't like
this do something else and find
something that
grabs you so that you stay with the
process anyway just some thoughts on
getting started in a new language thank
you bye
[Music]
you